Mark: You've got your scalpels...
Wade: Scalpels...
Mark: Over on the right
Wade: Yes.
Mark : You pick those up with just your forefinger and your thumb.
Wade: Okay...
Mark: Very delicate, very delicate
Mark: Not telling you to do it now. Put down-- PUT DOWN THE SCALPEL!
Wade: Are you sure?
Mark: --Put it down!
Wade: I think we need it.
Mark: PUT IT DOWN!
Wade: Ok, I'm dropping it.
(Monitor Beeping)
(Flatline Sound)
Mark: This is what happened last time
Wade: Oh no...
Mark: Okay... Alright then.
Wade: Well... Uh...
Mark: *Grunts*
Wade: D-do you know how to--
Mark: --Get the spoon...
Wade: Oh, I dropped  the spoon
Mark: Oh my God! That was the only tool we could use to scoop it out!
Wade: I-I got it...
Mark: Oh God!
Wade: I got it....
Mark: Wait shut up, shut up. There's another spoon, there's another spoon.
Mark: Oh my God
Wade: Oh God...
Mark: Oh my God!!!!
Wade: Noooo!!
Mark: F@%#!!
- Outro -